what according to you is the source of
defects in our safely
I can put it up put it this way quoting
quoting Friedrich Nietzsche to LA live
is to be unjust there is a kind of
Fisher that runs through every human
deed every every human heart which
leaves sustained in the world every act
of human beings is projected into the
world that is always already stained we
as human beings we as being so in time
beings of transcendence we are so to
speak irreparable to our to ourselves
and I think the great challenge that we
face is not so much how to save the
world but how to make all life flourish
in the world that cannot be saved ok
this is this is all to metaphysical for
me I want to get physical really one
definition of the world is the physical
nature of the planet the first thing
that Donald Trump says he will do is
abandon the climate change a call but
you only came into being last week sort
of amazing to me that actually if we're
talking about saving the world the first
thing is actually doing something about
arresting the appalling Lee threatening
atrocity of climate change the fact that
Donald Trump it's not a problem for him
actually that he could and someone who
by the way it has a large house in
Florida where slimy inundation is
already lapping the foundations can do
this means that actually reason is dead
the entirety of the election campaign
was a victory of Lies falsehood
irrationality over reason so the first
thing we have to ask ourselves is how do
we actually develop a form of
communication which is not intellectual
exactly I'm so interested in your in
your out brilliantly outrageous
interpolation how do we actually how do
we actually make reason entertaining how
do we speak how many Millennials are
there out there
darkness actually if you put up your
hands I couldn't see you anything right
okay okay not enough of you showed up to
vote in Minnesota an Arizona and vicar
and it's this is you know if we start
with the basic question of how to save
the planet Earth then we get to the
question of how do we find a language
that deals with the entertainment of
unreason right but I still want you to
elaborate on your opening statement that
on the enlightenment which was killed by
amusement or right why why your faith in
the Enlightenment why miroslav was
talking about the false beliefs of the
Enlightenment well I have very low
threshold of acceptability of the
Enlightenment I'm not talking dr.
Pangloss here and just saying the
possibility of effecting a political
decision by distinguishing lies from
truth that's you know kind of Ground
Zero the Enlightenment really things
follow from that that has been
essentially confounded it didn't matter
that you know went where Donald Trump
was caught out a lie he does he say in
America double down on the lie that
seems to be something new Marquis de
condorcet could probably not have
anticipated fascism to tell the Terry
anism authoritarianism in America this
is too much so it's unproductive and it
may not be true let's be calm and affirm
our values this I'm just going to say is
unproductive language right now let me
ask you how is it working for you how is
it working for you to call people
fascists and racism are you winning for
you is that a good many other really
days to try it you know was that a good
way Bailey at strategic operational
planning was that a good strategy to win
this election is surrender I think
calmness is capitulation it was a calm
did not work in 1933 ok will not work
now we need excitement but seemed also
important to me is that
we in the western end increasing Glee in
the broader than buster culture have
invested all of our energies to speak in
biblical traditions in turning stones
into bread into kind of a canonic
activity that organizes entirety of our
personal but also political icing elting
lives but the result of that is always
proving to be disappointing that the
levels of happiness have not matched the
levels of of the increase in wealth
increased in sense of also physical
well-being and I think there's a kind of
crisis of meaning that's that's haunting
the world today
you